one thing that i've done since i was 25
years old is learn how to set goals
put them in place and then manifest them
over periods of time in my lifetime if
you go back and listen to the rules of
success that i shot that show and i
think i was 4 35 years old 36 years old
in la jolla california i was living on
the ocean then and
you can go back to that you can look in
the 10x rule when i wrote the 10x rule i
shared a bunch of goals that was 11
years ago you can see over the last 25
years every single goal that i have set
for myself up to this point anyway i
have been able to achieve my wife my two
beautiful kids the condition that my
body's in today my finances the real
estate all of it started
with goals all of it started with the
idea that was in my mind and had not yet
been manifested in reality
i heard a saying once uh barbara
streisand said that there was not one
thing in her career that she had
accomplished tips on writing goals
number one write them down every day in
fact what i do is i write mine down on a
blank sheet of paper
i write them down in the a.m i write
them down in the p.m and i also write
them down anytime i'm disappointed or
discouraged
okay so i could actually write my goals
down more than twice a day always in the
am always in the pm first thing i do in
the morning first thing i did today
was i wrote my goals down second thing
what i'll do before i go to sleep
tonight is write my goals down it could
be on the same legal pad second thing i
write them down in present tense
in pt
present tense or even past tense
or past okay so i may write it as though
i have accomplished it what you don't
want to do is
write it down
one day i will love my job okay you want
to write down i love my job even if you
hate your job right now just like flip
it i love my job okay i love my wife and
kids i didn't have a wife and kids
uh my kids love me i didn't have any
children okay i wrote it down as though
it was happening okay um
write your goals down
whether or not you're achieving them or
not it doesn't matter that you're
achieving them okay this is gonna sound
a bit like you're deceiving yourself
which is what you're doing you're you're
writing down the future as though it's
happening today and or has happened
number four strongly suggest that you go
ten times bigger on your goals than you
think
what is accomplishable okay i say go big
or
go bigger baby
okay go big or go bigger there is
nothing wrong with big think
it doesn't cost anything okay you can't
get taxed for thinking big
and it's not just
okay i'm a dream big and big things are
going to happen okay i am going to
write down hey i'm trying to achieve x
in my life i'm trying to go from here to
10 times bigger than i can think
okay during the day i'm going to take
the actions that support that when i
write this down every day number five do
not be disappointed
in not achieving just keep writing
just because you're not hitting it just
keep writing it
uh i wrote down off and on from time to
time i wrote down for years
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
grant cardone and my take on his top 10
rules to success enjoy
rule number two get rid of poverty
mindset my dad worked his ass off and
when he died
he did good my mom had to sell
everything
and so i'm like okay that didn't work
but he was considered successful the
middle class successful briefcase good
job professional people respected him
saved his money had life insurance house
was paid for everything by the book
and she was unloading stuff the next
week because she was terrified and so
from the age of 10 to like
16 17 years old we were just scared dude
clipping coupons
buying everything on sale
single mother everywhere she goes she
knows they're going to rip her off the
plumber the roofer the car dealer
everybody's gonna rip her off right so
she thought save your money save for a
rainy day yeah you know penny saved is
right a penny earned it's not it's a
penny yeah right it's a penny yeah i
mean it's a penny dude yeah you won't
even pick a penny up today you ain't
with a penny dude
yeah you know 50 cent come on man
that's 50 pennies
rule number three take a long-term view
the third thing i would say about
wealthy people is they're
i mean different people have different
ways they invest but they tend to be
more
focused on the long-term appreciation of
an asset
rather than give me money this second
and and i think to get there they're not
stuck in this get rich quick thing it's
a delayed gratification yeah they're
more like yeah i'd rather have wealth
tomorrow than rich today
and they do have a distinction between
the rich and the wealthy the you know
the super wealthy are looking to create
wealth beyond
their own
means and needs like they're not
thinking about their kids their boat
their plane i know people think that but
that's not actually true they're
actually thinking about how do i create
wealth for a lot of people amazon's got
a million employees
yeah now most of them only earn minimum
wage but there's some people at the
upper level of amazon that are making
fortunes rule number four strive for
success success is vital i absolutely
maybe you've heard me say this before
it's worth writing down again success is
your duty it is your obligation and your
responsibility success to me is as vital
to my survival as oxygen food and water
shelter i gotta have shelter i gotta
have water i have to have oxygen i need
food okay i need love in my life okay i
need people i need human interaction and
i also need to win if you don't have
success in your life you will lose
discipline you will lose activity you
will lose contact and you will not be
consistent you will not have them this
is the vital part of success this is why
i'm pounding to you the only trick in
this universe if there is a trick at all
is you must be successful success is not
an option it is your duty it is your
obligation it is your responsibility
2022 if it's going to be good for you
and your family
if it's going to be great for you and
your family it is because you demand
success this year
and that means you demand success in
your relationships and your finances and
in your money uh your money and in your
business also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
rule number five invest your money what
should you do with your money well well
like saving money in a bank account is
ridiculous the only people that benefit
is the bank so what do you do with the
money then you you you use money first
thing people should invest in is
themselves
like you know best thing is people hear
that and they go what does that mean
though what do i do with the money go to
go to workshops go to seminars go to
whatever you're good at whatever you're
doing you're an astronaut invest in
yourself if you're an athlete investing
yourself
don't spend money on belts
yeah and looking good like invest in
your craft you're a comedian invest in
your craft and that means investing in
your skills uh uh uh a coach uh
what whatever whatever podcast yeah
whatever needs to get you known right
right and then also in in your branding
and your marketing like people have to
know you no matter how good you are if i
don't know you it doesn't matter right
so you got to get out there yeah how did
you guys run into me how did i run into
you yeah how did you find out about it
instagram good i invested a lot of money
making sure that people see that
instagram account right right our energy
money and energy right so uh invest in
yourself first
to become great at whatever you're doing
number two start investing in your
business
if that if you hadn't done that already
and the third thing is start investing
in things that will pay you every month
so you bought you buy a flow of income
rule number six have the right contacts
this idea that it takes money to make
money is not true it's a myth it's it's
it's the number one reason why i did the
show the discovery show to debunk that
on tv
that i didn't need any money at all uh
they they offered me a hundred bucks i'm
like just keep it like no no we got to
give it to you it's part of the show and
i'm like i don't need the hundred
they're like no but you got to take the
hundred as part of the show the entire
90 days
i never touched the first hundred they
gave me
and this was to prove to people do you
do not need money like it's just it's
not true you need money you do need
contacts
you need people you need people you need
people you need the right people though
the right people that are already in
play
okay just because a guy's got money
i remember a a billionaire friend of
mine uh you know he could buy a jet
and i said hey bob should i buy a jet he
said you should i shouldn't
meaning grant should because and he's
way wealthier than i am he could have
bought 40 of them he's like i don't have
a place to go in mine you have a you can
use yours every day
so you got to find somebody that's in
place somebody that not just has money
but somebody that wants to do more with
their money
so you'll notice in the first uh 10 days
i don't spend a hun any money i don't
spend money on shelter not on food and
not on water
nothing then what i do is i end up
accumulating assets
and it's unfortunate that the viewer
doesn't see this within five days i have
two vehicles one was given to me by
discovery and the other one was a forty
thousand dollar jeep
that i basically used
uh from ryan this guy i met
and told him i'm going to sell your jeep
i'm going to drive it around town and
put 10 miles a day on it and i'm going
to sell it well that's a 43 000 asset uh
my truck was worth four grand i still
had my hundred dollars i lived in a
forty six thousand dollar rv
that i was trying to sell
so yeah uh and what's the other thing i
did and i picked up ten thousand dollars
to do in a 15 partnership in the equity
of the upside of this guy's company so
literally in 10 days
i was accumulating contacts that could
get me equity and the important part of
that story is man go get you some equity
you know jay-z talks about this you're
getting you know so many of you young
brothers are getting in advance while
i'm picking up the equity rule number
seven show up
showing up means
showing up it don't mean you got to the
office
you understand doesn't mean you came to
work
for me showing up means i show up i've
been showing up since i was
25 years old man before that i wasn't
showing up
i was showing off
i was acting a fool
being a
fool high school i didn't show up i went
to class i never showed up my body went
in the room
see showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there and
then you showed up again and then you
showed up again and you showed up again
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework you show up for the
class you show up for the homework you
show up for the test you freaking get a
perfect grade means you keep showing up
to the next level
and i hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up's not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way
showing up is 100 of success so you got
to keep showing up showing up means
you're looking for deeper levels to show
up to pay attention
that's what i do every day every day i
come to work i'm like show up man show
up for every little problem show up for
every little opportunity show up for
every little little new nuance
little angle little particle little
movement that's why i see all this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up what's it why did
somebody pick that up
who's that new person here
hey you feeling all right today how many
times have i asked you that before you
all right today i know it's little
things
it's simple it costs nothing to do this
show up
it costs you nothing
and it makes all the difference when
it's showing up
you'll see things that no one else sees
and and you know the good news is
anybody can do this you just got to make
a commitment to show up rule number
eight surround yourself with success
the reason the guys on wall street and
the gals on wall street make so much
money
okay it's not because they're they're
they're like capitalists and they're
terrible people it's because they're
surrounded by people that are making
money man they're accountable by their
stock price they're accountable to their
production they got people around them
that expect them to win and do well and
also they're going to dinner waking up
at breakfast working out in the gym with
other people that are winning big in
life okay so you need feedback from your
environment and your network fourth
thing you need is you gotta have fifth
thing you need is you gotta have a
network of people that are encouraging
you
to kill it you gotta have the right
network you gotta have a lebron in your
game man if you're playing in the nba
and lebron's like i'm gonna take you
under my wing bro
okay kobe's like hey man i want i'm
coming back to be with you man what
would you deny that okay michael jordan
i want to be with you man tiger woods i
want to golf with you come on guys what
are you doing you cannot do this alone
you cannot do this alone are you kidding
me man let's say you want to be a
surgeon and a top surgeon in the world
is like i want to take you under my wing
what are you going to do i'm too busy
rule number nine be innovative you're
reading a book
okay you listening to music
going to an event
uh
speaking at an event
let's say you're speaking in an event
it's the 700th time you did that
presentation you got to show up new
again
johnny comes to work with his camera
we're doing a show today johnny needs to
show up new looking for new angles new
colors new you got to show up every day
new folks you're new man you're new
ladies and gentlemen you're new every
day you're new or
guess what you're old
[Music]
nobody wants old
i don't want to get old
i don't want stale
i don't want yesterdays
i don't want leftovers
i don't i don't i know i know when
somebody's repeating something wrote
they're just giving me the same
i don't mind some but it's got
to be fresh
i need some fresh
so i don't i don't mind a little bit of
i just don't want the same
thing
okay that guy's told that story a
thousand times and it looks like the
thousand thousand times not in a good
way either and rule number ten the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is don't get stuck in mechanics last
thing i'm gonna tell you is this
okay
don't
get
stuck in mechanics
when i'm writing my goals down i do not
know how i'm going to do it
so i merely sit down like i remember for
years i would write down i own a
helicopter i don't even know where this
concept came from i own a helicopter i
own a helicopter i own a helicopter
every once in a while i would show up it
would show up on a wednesday and not
show up for uh when i'm writing my goals
down right so i'm waking up in the
morning i wake up in the morning i write
my goals down and one day i write i own
a helicopter
i think back then it was uh i learned
how to fly a helicopter
okay it was stupid it was completely
ridiculous i'm like where'd that come
from
it just kind of floated into my mind i
wrote it down okay i own a jet
i'm like man i'm just being stupid right
now i own a jet and two helicopters
i don't know how that happened i didn't
i didn't know anything about jets uh i
would not achieve any of this by the way
until i was
years old 54 years old
the first private jet i was ever on was
the one
we bought
i didn't know anything about it i didn't
know how they fly i didn't know how they
work i didn't know what the cost of a
hangar was i know nothing don't get lost
in the mechanics i didn't know the fuel
cost i didn't know what it cost to buy
one do you finance them do you pay cash
do you get a tax rate i knew nothing
when i started writing this down the
helicopter would come after the jet okay
i bought a helicopter i didn't know why
so the point of that story is when
you're writing your goals down literally
sit down with a blank sheet of paper
first thing you wake up in the morning
and you just start zip zip zip zip zip
you right through them like this morning
i wrote down 40 billion in real estate
okay public i write down one word i'm
going public
see i know now that this this is in
present tense and or past tense i write
it in present or past tense i'm going
public okay i wrote down recently uh
a congressional hearing
people like what's a congressional
hearing dude i'm so big now they called
me into congress
they're going to have a congressional
hearing they're going to drill me
okay oh yeah then i wrote this down uh a
political office
now i don't know why
i don't know why i'm writing that down i
don't know how to achieve that i don't
know what it would mean i don't know
what it looks like i don't get stuck in
the mechanics don't worry about it
commit first commit first man just keep
committing it keep fueling and keep
writing it down
you got to commit first when you know
something's right folks commit
commit
go all in on the deal nobody knows what
you're what you're up to nobody knows
what's going on inside me i called my
mom that night and i said i met my wife
today and she's like well have you all
been out where did y'all go what did you
do i said no she hates me
and she's like she hates you grant it
takes two and this is what i knew from
being in business and if you're taking
notes it might be worthwhile it does not
take two to
tango it does not take two to make a
marriage and it does not take a buyer
and a seller what it takes is you
it needs to be you first you have to
decide they're selling the house and you
got to decide that they're buying the
house before any house makes a
transaction i had to decide that she was
going to be the girl before she could
see that i was going to be the guy you
guys with me all right 26 phone calls
all of them were light hey how you doing
you know i didn't mention that she never
calls me back
i didn't mention that she was breaking
my heart every time she didn't call me i
didn't mention the fact that her best
friend said i was too short
okay
you guys know what all your objections
are don't you like her a friend said
you're too short i said just tell me
what the real deal is i got to know what
the objection is i cannot handle the
unspoken objection what is the real deal
grant you're too sharp i said okay what
else what else you got
uh you're not a hollywood guy she's
she's an actress i wasn't in hollywood
i'm not an actor okay good what else
you're a businessman she thinks you're
too conservative okay what else what
else you got well you don't have a
prison record
you don't have a prison record no
tattoos she like bad boys okay how many
ladies here like the bad boys
just be honest
okay be honest the lady over here is
like yes
i love them okay so so i just continue
to pursue her because like somebody said
earlier sometimes people change how many
of your room have changed
how many of your room have changed
exactly you're going to keep changing
too some of you are not going to like
so so
i pursued her until one day because i
know this okay and you might want to
keep this in your collection of how you
handle
uh discouragement along the way
when you get a no would you agree that
no is a version of yes
how many would agree with that dude look
i mean think about it what's the
opposite of yes
what's the opposite of no
what's in between
maybe
so i always tell people when they tell
me no i'm like don't say no
say maybe
okay just say maybe oh well maybe grant
maybe but not right now excellent
because i know no's can turn into yeses
i said no to a lot of things in life and
then done them you've walked into a
casino before i am not gambling tonight
i will not gamble you came down to cabo
i am not drinking while i'm here
okay you some of you came down no
enriched bread while i'm here
no
chips no guacamole nothing okay and as
soon as you got down here you're just
like freaking hitting shots
eating guacamole slamming it in your
face right
so how do you get from no to yes
just show up in cabo
it's a maybe
right how do you get somebody to say go
go from not selling their house to yes i
will
get to a maybe
and then follow them up best advice i've
received my mom said hey invest in
yourself you'll never lose
i have reminded myself of that
so many times workshops i go to
events that i attend where i'm going as
somebody to get educated okay books that
i've read i'm like it's not a waste of
time
even even if you don't think you learn
anything it is not a waste of time you
think you think you haven't
that it was a waste of time or you
didn't learn anything because you hadn't
used it yet you may use that piece of
data one day
and so number one anything you invest in
time or or
or money in trying to improve yourself
you're not going to lose that you got to
take a risk you got to take risks you
got to take risks i mean that that is
what an entrepreneur does
like if
and a lot of people call themselves
entrepreneurs i'm like you you need to
look up the definition okay you are
violating what the one
most important thing about
being an entrepreneur take risks
because i was talking to a guy the other
day he's like i'm an entrepreneur i'm
like how much how much equity do you
have in your house he tells me like 200
000 pounds uh good how much money you
have in the bank uh 300 000. how much
money you have in retirement accounts he
had he had like 50 times more money in
all those things than he had in his
business i'm like man you're not taking
risk
you're you're actually avoiding risk
okay
so you need to go be the avoiding risk
person
so become just an investor
or saver the beauty salon the restaurant
the bar the bar owner
the consultant we've all had the
experience of
resenting our customers starting not to
like them
and it's because we become dependent
upon them
we have too few if we're resenting our
customer what is that saying about us
that we're not building our brand that
we're not growing that we're not selling
enough yeah you didn't go you didn't you
didn't build the top of your funnel out
enough
because this this part of it's easy
even though you hate them they never pay
you money this is the kind of stuff that
goes on they don't pay me enough they
always complain they never use the
product no matter what i do for them
they and complain okay they're
never happy blah blah blah right
well the truth is those are indications
that you didn't build your your customer
base wide enough
because you now resent them your
resentment is an indication that you
rely on them too much
and every time they complain to you it
reminds you that i'm too reliant on too
little and and we've all done it we all
do it i've done it uh right now i'm
doing it in my real estate i told my guy
ryan the other day i said we're
depending on this one guy too much
and he's like why do you say that
because i'm starting to resent him
so what's the first thing we should do
what are the what's the action steps
after that when we resent our customers
you you got to you got to understand
it's not about them it's about you
has nothing to do with them you need to
go wide you need to go get more
customers
if you resent facebook if you if
facebook pisses you off
it is because you are too
reliant on face the book three parts to
the real estate game number one
is the deal
i found me a good one right here i'm in
the heights one of the most desirable
neighborhoods in all of the 713.
number ones the deal number two is the
debt you got to get a bank that's
willing to lend on that we're working on
that right now
that market's insane right now now and
i'm still learning how to play that game
making connections getting relationships
with people i've had money quoted to me
at three and three three and three
quarters
all the way down to two point
uh seven five and then last night got
some money quoted to me at under two
percent in
sane in the membrane changes everything
in the game when you get your debt right
the third part of the deal is cash
equity how much can you put down to buy
the deal so many of you out there would
be looking at deals this size if you
knew
how to get the debt and the equity but
because you you think you're short on
debt and equity
you reduce the deal size or the location
or the quality of the asset most of you
are chasing the death the equity when
the troop mission should be chasing the
deal because the right deal with the
right story in the right location the
right traffic the right printer
it'll always bring the money i'll tell
you a story i just did a deal in boca
raton i paid 70 million dollars for the
deal
and i knew like i moved on this deal so
fast it was unbelievable because i knew
that market right i didn't have to do a
lot of research because i'd already done
the research so i still did the research
right because i'd already done a
research you know what i'm saying i'm
gonna go check out this restaurant right
now see how they're doing and um
bought the deal closed the deal very
little due diligence by the way
just wham
looking for reasons to buy the deal
because i knew the location we raised
the rents
500 a month already i've been in 60 days
we just had one maybe two rent two rent
uh leases come in and a thousand dollars
more
than they were before we bought them and
we got great plans for the property
we're going to do great stuff for the
tenants there
point is
when you raise the rents man guess what
you make the property better you have
more money to take care of your tenants
it improves the value of the property
and gives you some momentum in that
property
uh
and then momentum to buy more deals the
point is
dude find the right deal in the right
location at the right time and the right
price the debt and the equity
i called the lender today he's like i
paid 69 million they're like we'll give
you 60 million dollars for the debt on
that deal based on its performance just
in the last 60 days since you took
ownership
that is on unbelievable that means i
only need nine million dollars to buy
the deal and i've already raised 20.
again uh know your location
get some support around you uh real
estate is a team sport okay it's about
relationships about the debts about
relationships equity's about
relationship deals without relationships
there was a time when nobody knew my
name
all right nobody knew my name
i didn't i hadn't written a book i
didn't have 21 best-selling programs
i wasn't doing audiences my first gig my
first gig i talked to seven people
for eight hours
how long
like oh how long did that go on for
three years oh how long did people not
know me yeah oh
nobody knew me really until the last
three years so i want you guys to hear
that how many i've been doing this how
many years of doing that 20 i've been
doing this i've been doing the pitch
thing since 30.
i'm i'm 61. so 31. 31 years nobody's
known me until the last two or three
years maybe
and would you and then mike tyson said
man where you've been man
why doesn't everybody know you man yeah
why doesn't everybody know you steve
harvey dude everybody should know who
you are you should have a tv show but
that was my fault man i was thinking too
small
i was running down a little channel yeah
but too many of you guys you're trying
to run down too many channels in the
beginning
or or trying to cross all you got to get
good at one thing first yeah
you can't
you're not going to be great at two
things if you're not great at one thing
it's impossible yeah you can't serve two
ways at the same time man get good at
one wave get get good or the left
okay and and so you've got to get good
at one thing it doesn't matter if you
like it either you don't need to like it
to get great at it yeah like everybody's
like oh i got to follow my passion
particularly here in l.a yeah i'm an
artist
okay oh
i'm meant to do this dude you're meant
to do a lot of stuff yeah okay ask
steven spielberg he was not meant to do
one thing he's meant to do a lot of
things we all are
and so it's not it's not some freak
phenomenon that a guy can write
[Music]
fiction and non-fiction and do movies
okay and
um you know also be a massive investor
in companies yeah it's not true
it's
it's some guy oh how can a guy write you
know this and that and do all this and
put together these volumes and help
people and start to you know because
because he can and you can too yeah
everybody can but you got to get good at
one thing you got to groove into one
thing make sure you're certain about one
thing before you move on to the second
thing
because you're just gonna be like i'm
still in doubt about the first thing but
i'm gonna try to get great at this thing
and you know you didn't finish this
thing i respect a hundred dollars
so if you give me a hundred dollars
you know i respect that as a lot of
money gotcha now that being said it's
not going to be a lot for very long and
if you got two kids that need to eat
today it depends on what your needs are
right i got a wife and two kids so
i mean a hundred dollars probably gonna
last the whole day
uh but a hundred dollars for a minute
that's a lot of money now if i could if
i could figure out how to get more money
coming in
it's only a lot of money if you got more
money coming in i understand because i
can i can probably exhaust almost any
amount of money
this is this is a problem with the the
nfl the nba
the mlb the the the rappers when they
move on they got a pile of money but
what they don't have is
more money coming in gotcha and and so
now you know a million dollars is a lot
of money if you got a thousand dollars
every day coming in
because you can't get through it i
always tell elaine i said dude as long
as we make a dollar more
because of my net worth if i make a
dollar just one dollar every day
i mean one dollar today is a lot of
money because i mean it means i never go
backwards i need to think like the
google boys or the warren buffets or the
guys that are like dude they don't worry
about all that
they're worried about how big they can
get how big how big can they get how
long can they survive and and big big is
what works
you can't show me a small company or
small think that has ever survived
anything is this the your your quote
that says can't can't get big thinking
small you can't get big thinking small
and you can't get big
with small people before you diversify
go go bang on another door yeah you need
to become the freaking doorbanging
or the universe so i want to talk about
that right because can i use that word
here
you need to become like you need to go
bang
yeah you need to go bang on the door
they tell you to get out of the
neighborhood and you go figure out how
to bang on it again and not get arrested
yeah
like if you can figure that gig out i
guarantee you you will be the most
successful person your genetic code has
ever generated yeah anyone in your
family everybody i know says man learn
how to cold call i i have the career i
have today because i'm because i learned
how to cold so if you took everything
away from me right now
the things that are most valuable to me
you can't take away
so you take the plane away you take the
money away
take the real estate poor the portfolio
away
three years from now i'll be bigger than
i was
because now i have courage
if you guys can just find your courage
man
and that that's a muscle you got to go
build a muscle of courage i have courage
nobody can take that away from you can't
steal it from me you can't beat it out
of me what's your biggest
tip for anyone who
you know they obviously have all
intention purposes to to want to
collaborate what are some of the
the the best ins or the best ways around
money money of course pay money to play
money works yeah pay to play yep
universal language planet earth pay to
play
you know
whatever people i was doing before our
last conference and maybe we'd wrap it
up with this before our last conference
a guy came in my office from a big bank
and said hey i want to uh i want to talk
to you about lending you some money for
multi for your apartment building so i'm
like great
have you bought a ticket to my
conference
no i haven't i said i don't have time
for you
so it's like pay to play man it is the
simplest hack on planet earth i'm gonna
take garbage pieces of paper
dumb little pieces of rectangle paper
and give them to you to speed up my
process i don't know why
i don't know why i didn't know this for
45 years yeah and i don't know why i was
so hung up
on trading paper for access
it's what all the big players do yeah i
mean i even had this arrogant thing i'm
not paying i'm not paying to connect up
like
dude this is how everything works on
this planet i have belief now i know i
know what i can do now once you know
what you can do then you can do it a
second time and that's why so many
people can go bankrupt and then come
come right back because they know now
the first time you do it you don't know
the second time you do it you're like i
think maybe the third and fourth time
you're like i know for sure i can do
this
success is a contact sport
you cannot be successful if you don't
make contact
you guys interview people and then you
never follow anybody up man nobody
follows anybody up
i spent i spent two million dollars with
a lawyer that's never called me back
same thing for the bar birth same thing
for the cosmetologist same thing for the
plumber same thing for the roofer dude
you guys don't call people back because
you think they're not interested do you
think i'm only going to have one car
accident people that have one car
accident end up in three of them
okay divorcees guy gets a divorce
everybody here knows somebody's got four
of them
but he ends up with four different
attorneys
like you guys don't follow up you are a
business not a lawyer
the chiropractor has the same problem he
goes and spends all this money on
equipment he knows how to do an
adjustment he doesn't know how to build
a business
every city i've ever been to
when i work with ceos they say number
one problem here is the people
i said then you need to get better
so to the degree that you're having
problems with people you got to get
better and it starts with you
and you're only going to hire the people
like we we we have people come to us i'm
turning resumes down
i'm like
i can't see enough people like i got
people that too so so many people want
to work with us because we're successful
right
if you want good people
get big yeah everybody wants to work at
facebook
okay the average person at facebook
makes 250 just under 250 a year
which by the way if you do any kind of
financial literacy you would know that
guy walks away with 60 grand
250 in silicon valley converts to 60 000
bucks after all his expenses he's broke
he might not have 60 by the way
so um
you know just you're gonna have to go
through a bunch of people recruiting
should be the number one thing for every
company out there every entrepreneur
first thing you should look for is not a
sale that's what i did wrong i was
looking for a sale i should have been
looking for a recruit um
so focus more on team building than just
sales sales sales now now well you need
to recruit recruit recruit recruit and
that means you need to pay people now
we're back to that other ugly problem
that nobody wants to talk about
i need some money everybody wants to be
the boss nobody wants to pay the invoice
you take care of yourself every day you
got to do the work
some things you cannot delegate
taking care of your body food you eat
somebody can cook it for you you still
got to put it in
and then you got to take care of
yourself
and then you got to take your ideas and
your dreams
only you know what they really are
and only you and you alone
know what your real potential is
your wife can't do that for you your
husband can't your boss can't your
manager can't
god's not going to even do it for you
folks
you got to do that you want to be in
good shape you can pray for all you want
you want to get your money right you can
pray for it but you got to do the work
your destiny is waiting for you
but you got to do the work how do you
maintain a positive
opportunistic upbeat attitude during
times like this
you know i i look i struggle with it
just like everybody else this is not an
easy time it's scary uncertainties
everywhere
bad news everywhere
uh the thing the thing that i continue
to do is
i was just telling jared a few minutes
ago we're just thinking too small
you know let's let's we're thinking too
small
and so like i'm like where am i going
where am i trying to get to
uh because i could be seduced into a
beach right now pretty easily yeah i'm
gonna go lay on the beach
and i don't need to do all this
you know and then i'm like wait a minute
there's no beaches open either like
there's the caribbean shut down the damn
st bart's is shut down there's uh
everywhere you go there's problems right
so there's no getting away from that
where am i going yeah
so so i the thing i need to wake up
every morning hey i'm still going for 10
billion worth of real estate maybe 20.
yeah
why not 30.
so how do i do that got to stay relevant
got to keep paying my bills got to take
care of my properties got to show people
that i know how to get through tough
you can't expand if you if you fold
every hand you can't win if you fold
every hand
so you got to play the cards you got
right now it's tough
and then but i have to keep making
contacts with people that can actually
benefit me in 21 22 23.
i got i got to be i got to be a beacon
of possibility and potential and future
uh so so that when we go when things
start lifting off and we can do deals
um
i'm relevant to the conversation and i
got to cross my fingers dude and just
believe that
i got to believe that things are going
to get better and the first thing to
becoming a millionaire a
multi-millionaire a hectic millionaire
or a billionaire
and i've spent time with enough
billionaires now
is they have made decisions to get their
money right okay whether they're going
public or selling a product scaling out
they had to make a decision to get the
money the finance model of their
household their business their product
or their ipo right right if they want to
go to the market and become a public
company so number one get your money
right
it's not about product knowledge first
it's not about sales knowledge first
it's not about sales process first it's
not about the follow-up first or writing
the customer up first it's not even
about attitude first it's about get your
financial mental get your money mental
right okay because if you're satisfied
if you're happy where you are
financially why would you sell anything
else look let's face it you're on
commission you get paid to sell things
you get paid to close deals you get paid
to follow up
only when it works okay number one get
your money mindset right you need to
dream big i mean you cannot dream big
enough
i'm telling you you can't dream big
you can do more than you're doing
but you can't do more than you're doing
if you hang around with little thinkers
that could be your family members could
be your friends could be people you're
going to school with and hanging out
with look there's a time and a place to
hang out with those people
can't pick your family i mean they say
you can't i wonder sometimes we don't
actually do the picking
and just show up there
but i'll say that for another
conversation
but i do know once
once you get with your family the family
that you picked or they picked or
however that might work the selection
process
wherever you went to school or go to
school or where you grew up or how you
grew up or religion you grew up in or
whether you're white or black or brown
male or female the question's always
going to be
what can you do
to do more with your life
to find your mission to find your
purpose
to find what you're great at to get
great at the things maybe that you're
not great at that you don't even like
doing number one think big
telling you can do more and you will do
more than
than you ever imagined if you're ever
successful in your life if you ever hit
it
and you can
you will look back
10 15 20 years from now say god what was
i
what was i thinking i promise you
you know it's like 80 pounds of weight
looks like a lot
when you're five or six years old
later it's pretty easy to pick that up
no matter what your frame is as long as
you do the work as long as you do the
work and show up in the gym one day
you'll be able to pick that barbell up
just like in life okay the things that
you think are impossible today the
things that you hate today the things
that you aren't good at the things that
you think are a waste of time the things
that make you angry
are all opportunities for you first get
rid of the little think
and the old ideas
and the middle class mentality
i'm gonna go to work i'm gonna save some
money i'm gonna put it in the bank i'm
gonna give it to the man
what's the bank dude the bank doesn't
even keep your money
they hate money
cash is
it's trash
cash is garbage it's pieces of garbage
paper
it is only useful when it is used if
you're taking notes
they didn't teach you this in school
this should have been taught basic
fifth grade sixth grade not in not when
in high school or college
cash this is a piece of paper okay it is
a piece of paper it's worthless this is
a piece of paper this actually has more
value this piece of paper right here has
more value than this piece of paper
right here why because one person has
this piece of paper
2 000 people have this data
you understand
this piece of paper right here is
useless though until it is used
in people's lives
you have distractions
and you have opportunities to go do
other stuff and look at other stuff
[Applause]
you know it's like in indecisi
indecisiveness
is the weakness
as you wear so well
and it's like look you guys want to be
you want to be hoodwinked by the coved
you want to be hijacked by the election
you want to be uh thrown off because of
somebody's uh
comments about you
like the the universe will send you
endless
numbers of distractions
and and to people that are fully
completely committed
they're like yeah i saw that happen yeah
i heard there was a car wreck over there
a guy sent me something this morning uh
on from fox news
about this guy that was arrested i'm
like why are you passing this on to me
and i said do not never pass on bad
information to me i don't need it i
don't want it i'm not interested in it
by the way you're better than that and
all the people you know
the people you know don't need that
message
and at the same time by the way he sent
it to a friend of mine another friend of
mine my wife got it but nobody said stop
it
hey guys hey guys
papa's on a podcast sorry about that
so again you see that like like stop the
distraction stop the noise and and if
you don't say no to it it will continue
uh it will feed you
to be distracted and give you excuses to
not achieve the things that you're
capable of from 15 to 25 i was using
drugs every day
so when i tell you
hey you can do anything
i was a
habitual
daily drug user
overdosed three times
was brought back by people just
wandering into a room saying oh this
guy's in trouble
okay i was i don't know if i was trying
to kill myself at the time or i was just
didn't know what i was doing or stupid
or whatever like
i was a walking time bomb
and i was not to be trusted by my family
by my friends
there was no one in my life between 15
and 25 that i could have a positive
influence on i was a liability
to everyone in my life including my
family
and my friends and people i went to
school with and the places i worked at i
lost seven jobs in a row i was
unemployable
25 i went to a treatment center and said
i got to turn this around
i got to turn this around i cannot keep
using drugs they're bad for me i make
poor decisions when i'm using them
i i i go out with the wrong people hang
with the wrong people end up in the
wrong fights i literally got like when
you're using drugs you're going to pick
fights you can't win not in a lifetime
you're going to get in the wrong cars
make the wrong decisions the wrong
purchases
and you're going to miss a lot of great
opportunities
so first thing is
you can't do great things
if you're incapable of making great
decisions and when you're
under the influence
and i don't want to preach to you i'm
just telling you what what advice i'd
give myself if i was on the comeback and
i was
15 years old and being influenced by
everybody smoking the kush
it's cool now
it's probably going to be legal
everywhere
going out drinking on the weekends
forgetting everything that you did
and just making poor decisions so i tell
you hey you got you got to figure out
how how is that going to somehow
advance your life you're going to have
to make some hard choices if i'm a young
guy coming up young gal coming up how
can i pick great relationships when
everybody's under the influence
and again i don't mean to sound like a
like a
a preacher or anything because i'm
definitely not that we're gonna have a
great time this weekend
i'm here for a week we're gonna have a
lot of fun but i couldn't do that if i
was still under the influence every day
anybody ever surf you ever got covered
up by wave yes sir and it's throwing you
down and you're like
and i can't wait to come up and as soon
as you come up you're like oh my god
damn bam another one hit you
okay this is a tsunami
this is a tsunami
there is no place you can go and escape
what's going on here you can go get
another job we have many people that
have tried that already some of you
might be thinking about it you're going
to go some other place and you're going
to meet yourself again
and the tsunami will be wherever you go
there's no getting away from the tsunami
the only way out of this deal is to say
hey what do i have to sell
today
okay so right now right now dave did a
deal yesterday 9.95
what kind of business was it dave solar
60 months
did you ask the guy are you going to be
in business in 2025 yeah
what did he say well he it was a
three-year deal he didn't like the price
they said okay let's do five let's do
five years yeah good okay so so you guys
need to start asking people first of all
are you going to be in business next
year
you need to ask every person you need to
include a couple of words in in in your
pitch right now okay
hey are you going bankrupt
you need to ask them are you going to go
bankrupt because they're thinking about
it trust me
they are thinking about i'm going to
bust out here you need to bring it up
before they do this is straight out of
seller be sold initiate the objective of
the objection
the unspoken objection is what's going
to kill your deals
learn to discipline yourself if you got
to go to the gym every day if you hate
going to the gym go to the gym i don't
like going to the gym but i'm like i
don't like my body hurting either sooner
or later if you don't go to the gym and
work your body your body will
it will scream at you and it will hurt
lower back pains arms shoulders knees
you name it
it's always going to hurt and as long as
it's hurting how can you be fully
available for the people around you if
your body's certain two you got to eat
good foods okay got to make decisions i
ain't gonna eat junk
i'm not gonna eat the junk why why
because i'm saying no to junk
if you can start saying no to stuff
you can start saying yes to the good
things like my little girl right there
sabrina say hi sabrina
so pay the price today learn how to be
great at jobs you hate
that's paying the price get up early
go to bed early okay beat the sun up
every morning it'll give you so much
confidence i'm paying the price when i
do that when i get up before the sun
gets up i'm paying the price when i go
to bed at nine o'clock and i'm not
watching tv and movies and just being
entertained an effect of whatever's
coming my way i'm paying the price
when i don't waste the weekends the
weekends make you weak listen to me
weekends are for weak people
anything after 10 o'clock at night it's
for weak people
okay saturday and sunday staying up all
night weak people people are made weak
on the weekends
pay the price okay give up the weekends
for the next
five years and watch what happens
five years man that's a lot of weekends
that's what is that 250 weekends is that
right yeah 250 weekends that means i'm
ahead of the people around me
i'm paying the price today
in hopes that i could pay any price in
the future you failed the business no
problem
you restart another business
so the way to play this is let's go
ahead and give your business the best
shot
you need training you're going to need
sales you're going to need phone skills
you're going to need follow-up otherwise
it's going to fail okay now watch we put
it on a credit card
if we put it on a credit card and you
fail
the bankruptcy court picks up the visa
mastercard the american express
the training contract you
you you did with us lives on for your
next company
you guys understand that
100 of those people
will continue on in some other business
a few of them will commit suicide
okay oh i'm done
but the rest of them are gonna be like i
gotta go do something and they are going
to restructure and start another company
donald trump has restructured casinos
man this is not a new thing like the big
boys restructure okay
fail boom we restructure we'll create
something new i still got a business
okay you got to get this guy to see this
might fail but you won't because you
won't quit and you're going to be over
here the way i lead is i go do stuff
first time
and when i talk about doing stuff i'm
talking about i move the bar the only
thing i look at every day
is did i move the graph up
i'm just i like
i love that the the symbol of hercules i
think it was hercules holding the world
yeah
and and i imagine if he if it was a live
character he'd be pushing it up more all
the time that that's what i when i see a
graph i look at we graph everything
right i look grass and i'm like i want
to go be hercules
i want to lift it and that's all my
people see me doing every day i don't
i'm not an organizer i'm not a planner
i'm not the meeting guy
um i'm the i'm i'm i'm hurt i move i'm
hercules constantly moving that bar
moving the bar moving the bar i'm i'm
the one making the points right and so
i'm like look i don't
steve i'm going to make 40 points today
put 20 on the board dawg i don't need
you to do because you can't steve you
can't make
okay
right
uh so
me and ryan i'm like right right i'm a
race i'm gonna raise two million dollars
today i bet you can't even do half of
what i do
and what happens is
you know they see my energy is toward
activities that get results
not not not ideas or concepts there is
value in having a a a partner in your
relationships that is not stuck in
mechanics because the mechanics stop
people from the dream yeah
you know if the new year you know i want
to do this i want to do that the
resolution stuff the big mistake that i
make in my goal setting is the moment i
set a goal i want to move to how to do
it and when i do that when i move to how
to
it stops me really yeah immediately
because i don't have the money to do it
i don't have the time to do it
but i don't live there i'm too old i'm
too young
i don't have the connections
uh
i don't know how to write a movie make a
movie get a tv whatever right i want a
netflix deal okay i don't know anybody
at netflix
so you move into the mechanics and the
moment you move into the mechanics you
you you shatter the dream in the
business we've got great cash flow
reserves yeah yeah that's awesome and do
we take it out before have you how much
of the risk for risk for what risk
yeah you've been in business
six years six years dude in six years
you know just look back over the last
six years because this
i did the same thing i had all this
money sitting there
for the thing that was gonna happen
okay if you believe in the law of
attraction
you're planning for the thing and it
will happen like you're planning for it
it's going to happen right man we're
pushing hard on growth too yeah yeah
right but at some point you know you can
only spend so much you're like okay i
can't spend any more here we could spend
more you could yeah then then there's
your answer spend it dude don't sit on
it you had no reason to have a reserve
why don't we spend those research
because you're right a little bit of
doubt
a little bit of doubt it's gonna pay off
so you start you start you start
believing in the money more
than right start believing in the money
more than the possibility i hate risk
man huh i hate risks i hate risk too
that's why that's why i buy the kind of
real estate i buy
like every day the first sheet of paper
i get every day is how much cash i have
the reason i'm looking at that is not
bragging rights
it's because i want to get rid of it
it's like trash i want to get rid of
this money
i want to get that money to buy
something that has babies
right so i'm every day i'm looking i got
to get rid of this cash i had this much
cash i want to push it money's being
devalued worldwide right now nobody's
got more haters than that but it stops a
lot of people and it doesn't stop you
yeah because because because i i you
know it's a different
for me
like
i understand
that
if you get if you're going to get
success
you're going to get the haters that's
the price
or one of the costs that's one of the
prices okay so because it goes back to
what i said earlier
all haters
first of all we should not admire haters
the way we do we even call them haters
they're not haters
they're quitters
they're quitters all haters are quitters
like this should be this should be the
title of your your thing is a quiz all
haters all haters yeah including me
anytime i hate on something
okay
i am i quit on that thing like i hate
drugs i quit drugs i hate drugs i hate
people that use drugs i don't trust
people that use drugs like no drug is
safe for me
and and i know i believe that no drug is
safe for other people now some people
can be like no no i'm using cannabis
recreational it's cool man and i use
psychedelics and i do this good dude i
hate drugs i want to make it clear i
hate drugs and i i hate drugs for you
and i hate trucks for him i hate drugs
for everybody so i can be wrong but
right now i'm gonna hate drugs why
because i quit drugs
now if you're hating on grant cardone
and i hadn't done anything to you i'm
over here minding my own business or
building my own business
you know minding micromanaging my own
business so it grows so so if i'm doing
that okay and you're hating on me why
you hating on me
now he uses social media too much these
are every example i go over it's because
you don't use it enough he works too
much because you don't use you you don't
work enough uh he doesn't spend enough
time with his kids you don't even have
kids like i got people hating on me
because i got my kids on my plane oh
you're gonna ruin your kids
if i'm gonna ruin my kids i'm gonna ruin
them private
you know so so um what are you quitting
on like so i it's very very important
for me like when i hate on somebody i
need to understand
did i quit on something or am i
legitimately hating on this person
for a reason because i'm trying to make
a i'm trying to make a statement
publicly and there are
there are people i publicly hate on and
why do you do that
because i want to make it clear that
they should not be doing business with
this person they should not be admiring
this person they should not
like as an opinion leader i think i have
some responsibility to tell people do
you you don't want to follow that if
you're going to follow him don't follow
me yeah
you can't follow both of us
and think that you're going to get any
place which is a huge problem today with
social media what do you think it'll
take for you to get over insecurity
moving forward
i'm not trying you're not trying i'm not
trying to
i thought you said if you could get rid
of it you'd be able to do bigger the
unbelievable but but it's not it's not
it's not a target i have
letting go of insecurity no i think it's
just a human condition i think it's part
of the game i think it's part of being a
human being any more than i want to get
rid of my arms you know right or my legs
or my arms and my legs my body my body
is a limitation
yeah you know so um how do you manage it
better then like for people that are
saying i you know i want a 10x but i
always have insecurity and fear that i'm
going to fail and people are going to
show up and yeah the deal is going to
i'm going to go broke
how do you personally
get a conversation to yourself to the
insecurity and fear yeah it's not stop
it's come
you know for me for me fear fear the
things i i'm scared of i'm like
come on you know that it's calling me
says hey come play over here
it's an indicator it's a good indicator
not a bad indicator lean into it lean
into come play with me okay so i either
have fear because it's really dangerous
and stupid
or like physically dangerous yeah like
let me get to the edge of this thing i'm
gonna get on the other side of that
thing i'm probably gonna be scared yeah
now
why am i gonna be scared though
like because i don't know what it feels
like to fall you know this many floors
and hit yeah maybe it does maybe there's
no big deal about maybe dying is not
even a big deal right but i don't have
the exp i don't consciously have the
experience
so
you know i used to be like
i can't buy a 78 000 house i was
terrified the first house i bought
i don't know what i'm doing because you
have an experience i don't have the
experience man this this is the problem
and you're not going to have the
experience if you don't move through the
fear
and a lot of people do it once and then
they don't do it again you got like
it's not going away yeah it's just gonna
you're gonna get used to
you're gonna get used to the ski boots
you know the first time you put them on
man they're freaking banging your shins
like i can't man
but you just
wear into them people will listen to
three or four or five influencers
four of which don't make any money
like they're more interested in likes
and comments then they are a bank
account
i'm not interested in the influence like
i've never considered myself an
influencer i've considered myself a
businessman
so
i want to make money i want my companies
to make money i want the department to
make money i want the division to make
money to the degree that the company the
division the household is profitable the
country's profitable it means we're
doing good things
and so
um
when john comes and listens to me
and then listens to another guy says oh
you need to save your money and i'm like
you need to use every penny you have to
grow your brand
if you got to go into debt to grow your
brand do that if you got a if you got to
borrow money
to to get connections do that and this
other guy's saying don't borrow money
well the guy's going to do nothing
little dave's going to do he won't do
anything because there's a conflict in
his mind grant said do it dave said
don't yeah i won't do anything
so what the problem of maybe too much
information actually was too much too
much information that's conflicting so
he would be better off so i got to make
it clear dave's wrong
to my public
dave's wrong
but maybe day's right for you but day's
wrong for me because i want to expand
dave's right for you because you want to
stay small oh by the way staying small
never works
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there